Lenta y constantemente se gana la carrera.
La tortuga laúd es el reptil conocido más rápido,
con una velocidad máxima de 21.92 millas por hora.
¿Cuál de las siguiente ecuaciones, donde
"d" es la distancia en millas
y "t" es tiempo dado en horas, representa una velocidad que es menor que la de la tortuga laúd?
Seleccione todas las que apliquen.
Vemos que la velocidad de la tortuga laúd
es de 21.92 millas por hora,
sabemos que la velocidad es una relación entre la distancia en millas y el tiempo en horas, en este caso.
Si quisiéramos escribir una ecuación para
la distancia que la tortuga laúd recorre
en una hora, tenemos que relacionar la velocidad
que es de 21.92 millas por hora
y nuestra ecuación sería, "d" igual a "21.92t".
Cualquier coeficiente menor en esta ecuación,
representa una velocidad menor a la de la tortuga laúd.
Tenemos que ver cuál de estas ecuaciones
representa una relación entre la distancia
y el tiempo que nos indique una velocidad menor.
Cualquier coeficiente menor a 21.92, representa
una velocidad menor a la de la tortuga laúd.
Vamos a hacer una más.
Algunos discos de vinilo, llamémosles "Oldies",
giran a la velocidad de 78 revoluciones por minuto.
La tabla a continuación muestra las revoluciones
por minuto para tres pistas diferentes en
otro tipo de disco vinilo, llamado "Goodies".
¿Cuál tiene una mayor tasa de revolución,
"Oldies" o "Goodies"?
La tasa de revoluciones por minuto
de los "Oldies" es de 78.
Y vamos a pensar en las revoluciones por minuto
de las pistas que tenemos aquí.
En 3 minutos, éste hace 135 revoluciones,
¿cuántas revoluciones por minuto son?
Bueno, dividimos revoluciones entre minutos
y tenemos 135 entre 3,
120 entre 3 son 40 y quedan 15, el resultado
es 45 rpm en la pista 1.
En la pista 2, también son 45 rpm. 45 revoluciones por
4 minutos si nos dan 180 revoluciones.
Y en esta pista, si multiplicamos 45 revoluciones
por 5 minutos,
nos da 225 revoluciones por minuto.
Vemos que los Oldies van a 78 rpm
y los "Goodies" a 45.
Así que los "Oldies" hacen más rpm que los "Goodies".
Los "Oldies" tienen una tasa mayor de rpm.